hello everyone and welcome back to day
four of the meltwater Champions Chester
finals it is Arjun ericais versus Shakir
mamijarov and this is their fourth game
which is also very important because uh
Arjun is leading the match here he got
his first win and he got his win in the
second game game one and three ended in
a draw so mama jarov needs a win to
bounce back and force tie breaks now as
soon as I saw the final position of this
game I knew I was going to show it on
the channel uh because it's absolutely
spectacular it I knew it was gonna make
a wonderful pause the video moment so
hope you guys enjoy it as well uh now
let's dive straight into it uh Arjun has
the white pieces and he opens with E4 my
media goes for G6 the so-called modern
defense or the robots defense D4 Bishop
to G7 Knight to F3 and now Pawn to D6 so
might be uh having some ideas so maybe
Knight to D7 or Knight to C6 and then at
some point later on uh striking against
White Center with Ponte E5 Bishop to C4
Knight to F6 and now Queen to E2 we have
knighted the C6 and now Pawn to H3 so
nothing new here for the moment finally
Pawn to E5 and D captures on E5 we have
D captures and there is one game where
C3 was played but here Arjun just
castles King side and it is now as of
move 8 that we have a completely new
game
also castles uh Rook the D1 attacking
mom made out of screen on on d8 and
queen to E7 we have Knight to C3 now
with ideas of bringing the Knight to D5
Pawn to H6 and now Knight to D5 right
away now that's a too strong uh a steed
to just leave it there on D5 so Knight
captures and here uh Bishop captures on
D5 was played I guess a case could be
made for either capture several captures
not so much as Bishop to E6 will be
annoying uh but yeah it depends on how
you want to play this game you could
capture with the bishop or with the pawn
in the game Arjun played Bishop captures
on D5 and not Knight the D for Mama
jarov also forces a trade as the queen
on E2 is attacked so Knight captures
with e Captain D for the bishop nicely
defends that pawn and the bishop to F
form
um arjun's Bishops are developed very
nicely and now Rook to E8 here with the
ideas of maybe C6 you chase away the
bishop and then you pick up the E4 Pawn
but picking up the E4 Pawn is not uh as
easy as you would think as long as this
bishop controls this diagonal so here we
have Pawn to E5
which is very very interesting uh you
you might consider also something like
Rook D1 if you just were worried about
this but this is also a very nice spawn
to E5 and now if you capture an E5 which
you can the problem is uh after Bishop
captures an E5 Rook D1 you don't have F6
because the bishop controls this
diagonal you would have to trade here at
Bishop to F6 captures captures and after
characters and captures white would
finish by capturing the C7 pawn and yes
the material is equal both players have
a rook and the bishop pair and the six
pawns but white has two Pawn Islands
black has three Pawn islands and it will
be much much uh harder for black to
defend his pawns uh with perfect play
probably a draw but it will be much
harder to play with black so instead
after E5 we have C6 chasing with the
bishop Bishop to B3 and now Pawn to C5
we have Queen to D2 now going after the
H6 pawn and pawn to G5 Bishop to G3 and
now Bishop to E6 now once the bishop is
eliminated probably mamajar will be able
to capture an E5 Bishop captures an E6
Queen captures and now Ponta F4 first
eliminating
um the G5 Pawn which is uh in arjun's
way of going after the H6 pawn and also
for the moment defending the E5 Pawn so
if Shakira wants to go through he will
have to capture an F4 which he does g
captures on F4 Bishop captures and now
Queen to G6 this is a very interesting
move because uh capturing an E5 was also
interesting I'll just show what happens
if Bishop captures on E5 now Rook to E1
isn't all that impressive because you
can play Bishop captures on F4 and
attack the White Queen but white can
ignore you and just capture the bishop
however now Comes The Rook a queen
captures Rook on E1 Rook captures and
Rook captures an E1 with check King H2
and now let's say Rook to E6 guarding
the H6 pawn and you would get this
position where shahidar would have two
Rooks for a queen he would also be up a
pawn and if anyone is to be preferred
here it is definitely black so instead
after Bishop captures an F4 uh he goes
for uh Queen to G6 because this is not
force the uh uh if Bishop captures uh uh
you don't uh have to play Rook D1 I mean
you can just capture Bishop captures
Queen captures Queen captures on H6 and
now Queen G7 let's say you trade queens
and now it's uh equal material equal
equal end game uh probably a very quick
draw so instead Queen to G6 that's why
Mama Daryl didn't do it uh Rook to F1
and now Bishop captures an E5 finally
grabbing that pawn bishop captures an H6
rooked the E6 attacking the bishop and
the bishop back to F4 we have Rook 8 to
E8 mommy jar of doubles up on the E file
and Rook to F3 preparing Rook to G3 to
win the black queen so Bishop to G7
closing of the g-file Rook the G3 and
queen to H7
uh still uh keeping an end at C2 Pawn uh
Shakira really wants to play Rook D2 and
grab the C2 Pawn so he creates a pass to
D pawn and uh of course he wants to push
it all the way so Rook to F1 by Arjun uh
Rook to E2 attacking the queen and
remarkable as this position is uh you
think black is completely uh crashing
through here white is just better here
look at this queen to A5
and there's a very specific reason why
white is better but unfortunately for
Arjun he didn't realize it even though
they were both uh really well on the
clock they had some like five or six
minutes on the clock each and here Rook
captures in C2 mamidaro grabs the pawn
and uh he's now completely lost but it's
not clear why and if it was clear of
course Arjun would play it it's uh uh
not at all clear so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Arjun uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting any of
the winning moves like Queen to C7 or
Rook to E1 but there is one that makes
black resign instantly and that of
course is Bishop to E5 so if you found
this then truly congratulations you are
a master of uh spotting incredibly
difficult to moves the spot uh because
now black can just resign there is no
move black can make here you are either
facing Rook captures on G7 and you're
gonna lose your queen or if you don't
like that you can play something like
let's say Rook characters on E5 and then
just Queen to d8 with check Rook to E8
and queen captures with Checkmate so
there is no good way to deal with Bishop
to E5 even if you ignore it even if you
play something like Rook to C8 even
Bishop captures on G7 is enough and now
if Queen captures you can even go for
this very nice Queen to E1 you don't
have to capture or you could just
capture Rook captures on G7 King
captures and queen T1 and you have a
queen and Rook for two Rooks so of
course completely winning unfortunately
Arjun doesn't find this which is a
really funny for a very specific reason
that I will not mention uh so I don't
spoil anything for you but here Arjun
played Queen characters on A7 instead
King the HH Shakira realizes that that
Bishop should definitely be able to move
Queen captures on B7 and now Pawn to D3
he starts advancing his past Pawn King
to H2 and the now Bishop to D4 a weird
move I have no idea why shakaria played
it and it really makes no sense uh
probably there is a reason why he played
it like I said they were they both had
enough time it's not like they had they
had a few seconds on the clock and
that's why he played Bishop to D4 I just
can't figure out why why Play Bishop to
D4 it doesn't seem like it's doing all
that much but okay uh he probably had
something in mind but Arjun played Queen
to C6 and now Rook C the E2 and uh so
the position is again completely winning
for Arjun but it's not um uh winning
like you'd expect in the previous pause
the video moment that there was just
like wow what a move here it's actually
a forced Checkmate in three but again
you have to really really look hard to
find it uh so feel free to pause the
video for the second time and try to
find your way out of this mess while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
that it is again Bishop to E5 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show yes Bishop to E5 check and this is
what Arjun now played and there really
isn't anything you can do here uh Bishop
captures uh because uh well and of
course it was in this position on move
33 that chocolate resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here a
problem is that if you capture with the
bishop then the the Rooks are no longer
connected basically by playing Bishop to
E5 uh you disconnect the two Rooks the
two Rooks are no longer protecting each
other so the real threat is Queen
captures on E8 and if you capture with
the bishop that thread Still Remains
Queen captures Queen the G8 Queen
captures and G8 will be Checkmate if you
don't uh capture with the bishop if you
capture with the Rook then the bishop no
longer guards the F6 Square so now Queen
F6 check again ends in Checkmate and if
the other Rook captures doesn't really
make all that much difference because
the bishop still I can't reach the F6
Square Queen F6 check Queen uh G7 and
now Queen captures and G7 will be
Checkmate and other than that uh after
Bishop to E5 you really have no options
your only other option is to play Pawn
to F6 which again leads to Queen
characters on G8 and uh the exact same
Checkmate Queen to G8 Queen captures and
G8 and this will be Checkmate so
incredible stuff uh it'd be it'd be way
cooler if Arjun uh spotted it the first
time but um he was never really in in
any trouble his position was always
better and he was able to find now
Bishop to E5 which is uh also nothing
short of spectacular uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
Arjun wins the second game against
chakra mamidara with two wins two draws
he wins uh his first match and these are
now the standings after four rounds you
can see that Magnus
in first place with 12 points and Yanks
used of Duda was unable to follow Magnus
he lost
who is third with seven points Wesley so
with six points Anish girian pregnant
with four points and Arjun irregasi and
ashah mamidyarov in seventh and eighth
place with three points so now uh now
the clash between Magnus and Duda which
is coming up next I believe uh will be
even more interesting uh as uh Duda
needs to beat Magnus to bounce back if
he wants to retain uh uh catch up to
Magnuson and uh try and get a lead in
the tournament uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank ravishing reptiles YouTube
Harry Barton Mario's Clinic friends
Sarah and Carmen uh polyphronio for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
once again big congratulations to
everyone who found Bishop T5 it's I mean
it's uh it's a spectacular move see you
soon